>> Laura: BROWARD'S BROKEN
PROGRAM AND DEADLY EFFECT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THE MORE WE LEARN ABOUT THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN FLORIDA,
THE MORE IT APPEARS THAT A
BROWARD COUNTY INVENTION MAY
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN WHAT
HAPPENED.
NOW, WHAT AM I TALKING
ABOUT?
IN 2013 BROWARD COUNTY AND
THEIR NEW SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT ROBERT RUNCIE
HAD A NOVEL IDEA.
LOWER SCHOOL EXPULSIONS AND
ARRESTS BY REDUCING POLICE
INVOLVEMENT.
SOUNDS SIMPLE.
THEY CALLED IT THE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
APPRECIATING RECIDIVISM
THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES,
MENTORING, INTERVENTION,
SUPPORT, AND EDUCATION.
QUITE AN ACRONYM.
YOU SEE, IN 2011 INTO 2012
SCHOOL YEAR.
BROWARD HAD THE HIGHEST
PUBLIC SCHOOL RELATED ARREST
RECORD IN THE STATE MORE
THAN 1,000 KIDS IN THAT YEAR
ALONE WERE ARRESTED.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
EDUCATION SECRETARY ARNE
DUNCAN AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
ERIC HOLDER WERE SO
IMPRESSED BY THE PROMISE
PLAN IT INSPIRED THEIR OWN
NEW NATIONAL GUIDELINES.
>> AS IT STANDS FAR TOO MANY
STUDENTS.
FAR TOO MANY STUDENTS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY ARE DIVERTED
FROM THE PATH TO SUCCESS BY
UNNECESSARILY HARSH
DISCIPLINE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT EXCLUDE THEM
FROM SCHOOL FOR REALLY MINOR
INFRACTIONS.
TOO OFTEN, SO-CALLED ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICIES, HOWEVER
WELL INTENTIONED THEY MIGHT
BE, MAKE STUDENTS FEEL
UNWELCOMED IN THEIR OWN
SCHOOLS.
THEY DISRUPT THE LEARNING
PROCESS.
AND THEY CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT AND LASTING
NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON THE LONG
TERM WELL BEING OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: I WOULD SAY A
VIOLENT KID WHOSE OUTBURSTS
TOLERATE YOU HAD WEEK AFTER
WEEK LEADING YEARS LATER TO
A SCHOOL SHOOTING ALSO HAS
LASTING NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
YOUNG PEOPLE AND DISRUPTS
THE LEARNING PROCESS, ERIC.
BUT I DIGRESS.
THE OBAMA BUREAUCRATS
INCENTIVIZED BROWARD TO GO
EVEN FURTHER, AWARDING THE
DISTRICT NEARLY $54 MILLION
IN GRANTS TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS IN POVERTY
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE STANDARD THAT THEIR
LIVES ARE ACTUALLY
IMPROVING?
FEWER ARRESTS AT SCHOOLS,
LESS POLICE INVOLVEMENT,
FEWER DISCIPLINARY PROBLEMS,
AT LEAST ON PAPER.
SO SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WERE BASICALLY PAID TO DEAL
WITH STUDENT CRIME INHOUSE.
AND KEEP THE COPS OFF THE
PREMISES.
HAD NIC LAZARUS
NID NIC LAZARUS
NIKONIC LAZARUS
NIKOLAC LAZARUS
NIKOLAS LAZARUS
NIKOLAS CAZARUS
NIKOLAS CRUARUS
NIKOLAS CRUZRUS
NIKOLAS CRUZ BS
NIKOLAS CRUZ BEEN ARRESTED
OR CHARGED BY POLICE FOR
BRINGING KNIVES OR BULLETS
TO SCHOOL OR OTHER
INFRACTIONS.
HE MY NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BUY THAT GUN HE USED TO KILL
17 PEOPLE.
WHEN CNN'S JAKE TAPPER
PRESSED SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL
ABOUT HIS OFFICE'S APPROACH
TO STUDENT CRIME, HE SAID
THIS.
>> WHAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO
IS THE PROMISE PROGRAM.
AND IT'S GIVING THE SCHOOL
THE SCHOOL HAS THE ABILITY
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
NOT TO CALL THE POLICE, NOT
TO GET THE POLICE INVOLVED
ON MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES.
AND TAKE CARE OF IT WITHIN
THE SCHOOL.
IT'S AN EXCELLENT PROGRAM.
>> Laura: WHAT DID WE EXPECT
HE WAS GOING TO SAY UNTIL IT
HELPS A MASS KILLER MAINTAIN
A CLEAN RECORD UP UNTIL THE
TIME OF HIS SHOOTING, THAT
IS BROWARD CUT SHERIFF UNION
PRESIDENT JEFF BELL REVEALED
THIS TO ME LAST WEEK.
>> THEY DON'T WANT THE
POLICE OFFICERS MAKING
ARRESTS ON CAMPUS AND ELM
THEY DON'T WANT THE WARRANTS
TO BE SESHEDZ ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE THERE
IS BAD STATS AT THE SCHOOL.
I PLACE A LOT OF BLAME ON
THE SCHOOL ALBERTO WITH THAT
AND AT STATE.
PROFIT.
FOR EXAMPLE.
>> THE PROBLEM IS WHEN THAT
PROGRAM STARTED WE TOOK ALL
DISCRETION AWAY FROM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
AFFECT APPEAR ARREST IF WE
CHEESE TO.
>> Laura: THAT WAS STUNNING.
NOW, BROWARD SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT ROBERT
RUNCIE, SHERIFF ISRAEL, AND
THE OBAMA BUREAUCRATS THAT
CREATE YOU HAD THIS PERVERSE
INCENTIVE TO HIDE STUDENT
CRIMINALITY ARE DOWN PLAY IT
HAVE A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO
DO.
BY TURNING BROWARD SCHOOLS
AND THOSE ACROSS THE NATION
INTO THESE SOCIAL JUSTICE
PETRI DISHES, THEY MAY HAVE
FACILITATED A LUNATIC.
AND THEIR SOFT POLICIES HAVE